Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. There is no God but Allah, and Muhammad is his messenger. So runs the profession of faith familiar to some two billion people worldwide. But who was Muhammad? Where did he come from? When did he live? And what can we as historians know about him? Tom Holland, difficult questions, but a fascinating subject. It's such a fascinating subject. And it's one that I spent
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。万物非主，唯有真主，穆罕默德是真主的使者。全球约有二十亿人对这段信仰表白耳熟能详。但穆罕默德究竟是谁？他从哪里来？他生活在什么年代？作为历史学家，我们又能了解关于他的什么信息呢？汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），这是一个棘手的问题，但也是一个引人入胜的主题。这是一个非常引人入胜的主题。而且，这也是我花了
about five years of my life wrestling with. And to be honest, it was so challenging. It was kind of challenging intellectually, but also challenging because, of course, when you're writing about Muhammad, it's not like you're studying Nero or Alexander the Great. You're studying someone who is incredibly important to, as you said, 2 billion people. So you are dealing with very, very profound issues. And so I felt slightly tense about returning to this subject, I've got to say. But I think it's incredibly worth doing because I think it is fascinating in and of itself, but also because I think it raises really interesting questions about the relationship of history to belief, to the dimension of the supernatural, to all kinds of things like that. So really, I mean, the idea that we're going to do this in under an hour seems optimistic, I think.
大约五年的时间去深入探讨的主题。说实话，这个过程非常具有挑战性。它在智识上具有挑战性，但同时也充满挑战，因为当你撰写关于穆罕默德的文章时，这与研究尼禄（Nero）或亚历山大大帝（Alexander the Great）截然不同。你研究的是一个对你刚才提到的二十亿人来说极其重要的人物。因此，你正在处理非常、非常深奥的问题。坦白说，再次回到这个主题让我感到有些紧张。但我认为这绝对值得去做，因为我认为它本身就极其迷人，而且我也认为它引发了关于历史与信仰、超自然维度以及所有诸如此类事物之间关系的非常有趣的问题。所以说实话，我们打算在不到一个小时的时间内讲完这个，听起来似乎有点过于乐观了。
But I think we should try and do our best. We should do our best. I mean, what's interesting is obviously Mohammed is clearly one of the, you know, two, three, four people who have most shaped the course of human history. I mean, if you if we did, did you there was a book that was kind of like the hundred greatest, the hundred most influential people in history. Did you have that? Was he number one? He was number one. And it was kind of slightly mad book because I remember it had the Earl of Oxford.
不过我认为我们应该尽力而为。我们应该尽力而为。我的意思是，有趣的是，穆罕默德显然是对人类历史进程影响最大的两、三、四个人之一。我是说，如果你……以前不是有本书吗，类似于“历史上最伟大的100位人物”、“历史上最具影响力的100位人物”。你读过吗？他排在第一位吗？他排在第一位。那是一本有点疯狂的书，因为我记得里面有牛津伯爵。
The guy who wrote it was convinced the Earl of Oxford. Oh, really? I did a similar exercise when I was at school. You know, when I was about 12, we had to rank the 10 top people in history. Do you know who mine was? James Callaghan. No, it's Martin Luther. That would appeal to you.
写那本书的人坚信牛津伯爵是……哦，真的吗？我上学时也做过类似的事情。你知道的，我大概十二岁的时候，我们得给历史上的前十位人物按重要性排序。你知道我的第一名是谁吗？詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）。不，是马丁·路德（Martin Luther）。这倒挺符合你的风格。
Anyway, this is a bit of a sidetrack. Mohammed, so obviously neither of us are Muslims. No. So we're approaching this, it should be said at the outset for Muslim listeners, we are approaching this from the perspective of Western non-believing historians, aren't we? Because I remember when I began looking at this, I kind of felt, well, I'm neutral because I don't
不管怎样，这有点扯远了。穆罕默德，显然我们俩都不是穆斯林。没错。所以我们在探讨这个问题时——必须在一开始就向穆斯林听众说明——我们是以西方非信徒历史学家的视角来探讨的，对吧？因为我记得当我开始研究这个课题时，我觉得，嗯，我是中立的，因为我不
believe this. But of course, my position of non-belief is not a neutral position at all. No. And the assumptions that I assume that an angel did not speak to Muhammad, I assume that the Quran is not of divine origin. And therefore, my understanding, I'm sure your understanding of Muhammad is predicated on that. But of course, that's not a neutral perspective at all. So I think it's important to flag that up before we start. There are a lot of very respected scholars of early Islam who are not themselves Muslims. I mean, we'll probably be talking about some of them later in the program. So people who are not themselves Muslims. I mean, we'll probably be talking about some of them later in the program.
相信这个。但当然，我不相信的立场根本算不上中立的立场。没错。而且我默认天使没有对穆罕默德说过话，我默认《古兰经》并非神圣起源。因此，我的理解——我确信你对穆罕默德的理解——也是基于这一点的。但当然，这根本不是一个中立的视角。所以我觉得在开始之前指出这一点很重要。有许多非常受尊敬的早期伊斯兰教学者，他们自己并不是穆斯林。我的意思是，我们稍后在节目中可能会谈到其中一些人。所以，他们本身并不是穆斯林。我的意思是，我们稍后在节目中可能会谈到其中一些人。
So people who are fascinated by the history of Arabia and by the way in which Islam spread from its beginnings across the Mediterranean world, across the Asian world and so on, but they're not necessarily themselves Muslims. So I think you can reasonably want to talk and write about it without being a believer yourself. Anyway, listeners will be the judge of that, I suppose. So why don't we start, since it's such fascinatingly sort of mysterious, but also contentious territory, why don't we start by you giving us a short kind of rundown
所以他们是那些对阿拉伯历史着迷、对伊斯兰教如何从其发端传遍地中海世界、亚洲世界等方面的方式着迷的人，但他们自己不一定是穆斯林。因此，我认为你完全可以想要谈论和撰写它，而无需自己成为一个信徒。无论如何，我想听众自有公断。那么，既然这是一个如此引人入胜、充满神秘色彩且饱受争议的领域，我们为什么不从你为那些对这些材料不熟悉的听众简要梳理一下开始呢？
for listeners who aren't familiar with the material of the traditional account of the life of Muhammad. So if I go into an encyclopedia, what am I going to find about Muhammad's life? So the context is the 7th Christian century, beginning of it. The context is a world where the Near East is divided between the two great superpowers of Persia and Rome.
关于穆罕默德生平的传统叙述。因此，如果我去翻阅百科全书，关于穆罕默德的一生，我能找到什么？背景是公元7世纪，也就是7世纪初。当时的背景是近东地区被波斯和罗马这两个伟大的超级大国所瓜分。
Rome, of course, now ruled from Constantinople. Muhammad is born in a city called Mecca, which lies in an area of the Arabian Peninsula called the Hejaz, a thousand miles from the Roman frontier in Palestine. um he is uh a merchant um he is married to uh a woman who who is herself a merchant she he acts as her agent um he comes to the age of 40 and and 40 in antiquity is the it's the age where you have your midlife crisis and muhammad has perhaps the most epical midlife crisis in history when he starts hearing voices and this unsettles him because hearing voices in mecca where he's growing up is is potentially a mark that you've been seduced by a demon but he gets reassured that actually he's being addressed by an angel angel gabriel i think his name is gab Gabriel and he is being hailed as the last of the prophets
罗马，当然，当时是由君士坦丁堡统治。穆罕默德出生在麦加（Mecca）的一座城市，该城市位于阿拉伯半岛被称为汉志（Hejaz）的地区，距离巴勒斯坦的罗马边境有一千英里。嗯，他是一个商人，嗯，他娶了一个同样是商人的女人，他担任她的代理人。他到了40岁，在古代，40岁正是你遭遇中年危机的年纪，而穆罕默德则经历了历史上或许最具划时代意义的中年危机——他开始听到声音。这让他感到不安，因为在麦加——他长大的地方——听到声音可能被视为你被恶魔诱惑的迹象。但他得到了安慰，实际上是天使在对他说话，我想他的名字叫天使加百列（Gabriel），他被欢呼为先知中的最后一位，
the seal of the prophets and he is stands in a line of descent going back through Jesus through Moses all the way to Adam and his revelations are essentially the the the last the last chance that humanity has to live according to God's rules. So Muhammad starts to say this. Lots of people in Mecca think he's mad, but some don't. Among them is Khadija, his wife, and various other people start to rally around him. Khadija dies, but Muhammad continues with his prophetic mission. And in time, hostility to his growing number of followers becomes such that he and his followers are forced to emigrate, to undergo what in Greek is an exodus, and in Arabic is a hijrah. And they go to a town called Yathrib.
先知中的封印。他站在一条追溯到耶稣、摩西，一直到亚当的传承世系中。他的启示本质上是人类按照真主的规则生活的最后机会。于是穆罕默德开始宣讲这些。麦加的许多人认为他疯了，但也有人并不这么认为。其中包括他的妻子赫蒂彻（Khadija），以及其他各种开始团结在他周围的人。赫蒂彻去世了，但穆罕默德继续着他的先知使命。随着时间的推移，对他不断增加的追随者的敌意变得如此之大，以至于他和他的追随者被迫移民，经历了一场希腊语中的“出埃及记”（exodus），即阿拉伯语中的“希吉拉”（hijrah）。他们前往了一个名为叶斯里卜（Yathrib）的小镇。
So that's modern day Medina. Well, because it comes to be called, so Medina is a city, it comes to be called the city of the prophet. And in Medina, Muhammad essentially, guided by these divine revelations, sets up a community, a state. He takes over the running of the city. He expels those or slaughters those who do not subscribe to his teachings and his revelations. He defeats the Meccans. And by treaty, he's allowed back into Mecca. And when he comes into Mecca, he topples the huge number of idols that exist everywhere. And he establishes Mecca, which reaches back to the beginning of time. It's been a holy place since the origins of time.
这就是现代的麦地那（Medina）。因为它后来被称为……所以麦地那是一座城市，它后来被称为“先知之城”。在麦地那，穆罕默德基本上在这些神圣启示的指导下，建立了一个社群和一个国家。他接管了城市的运营。他驱逐或屠杀了那些不认同他的教义和启示的人。他击败了麦加人。通过条约，他被允许重返麦加。当他进入麦加时，他推翻了到处都存在的众多的偶像。他确立了麦加的地位，麦加的历史可以追溯到时间的开端。自时间的起源以来，它就一直是一处圣地。
It's a shrine that was established by Abraham and his son Ishmael right back in the beginnings of time. And so Medina and Mecca are consecrated as these two cities that are hallowed by the role that they play in the life of the prophet. He dies, but his followers then take his message out into the world and inspired by these revelations that in time will be bundled together to form a single Quran, a single text of revelations um people who come to be known as muslims swallow the persian empire whole dismember a huge chunk of the roman empire spread westwards to the atlantic spread eastwards as far as the gates of china um and the result is the muslim world that we have today yeah very good and so that is why, he could be voted the most influential human being who's ever lived.
这是由亚伯拉罕（Abraham）和他的儿子以实玛利（Ishmael）在时间的开端建立的一处圣地。因此，麦地那和麦加被奉为两座圣城，因其在先知生平中所扮演的角色而受到尊崇。他去世了，但他的追随者随后将他的信息带到了世界各地，受到这些启示的激励——这些启示最终将被汇编成一部单一的《古兰经》，一部单一的启示文本——被人们称为穆斯林的人吞并了整个波斯帝国，肢解了罗马帝国的大部分领土，向西传到了大西洋，向东远至中国的门户。其结果就是我们今天看到的穆斯林世界。是的，非常好。因此，这就是为什么他可以被投票选为有史以来最具影响力的人类。
Well, that was a bravura performance, Tom. So we're talking a life that runs from about 570 to 632 or so, I think are those the conventional dates, aren't they? Right. Well, yes. But those dates are inevitably contested. Yeah. Yes, but those dates are inevitably contested because there are all kinds of historical questions that surround this narrative. So we have a question from Diogo Mugado who asks, what can be ascertained with some confidence about Muhammad's life?
好吧，这是一场精彩绝伦的表演，汤姆。所以我们谈论的是一个大约从570年持续到632年左右的生命，我想这些是常规的日期，对吧？对的。嗯，是的。但这些日期不可避免地会受到质疑。是的，没错。但这些日期不可避免地会受到质疑，因为围绕这一叙述存在着各种各样的历史问题。因此，我们收到了来自迪奥戈·穆加多（Diogo Mugado）的一个问题，他问：关于穆罕默德的一生，有什么是可以带着某种确信被确认的？
And that's a question to which there is a whole range of answers. And at one extreme, you have people who say that the traditional accounts can be completely trusted. And at the other end, you have people who say that basically we can't know anything about him. In fact, there are even some who argue that he didn't even exist. And the reason for that is that essentially, if we want a narrative account of Muhammad's life, we're dependent on texts that were first written down, or at least surviving texts that were written down. They date to about two centuries after the lifetime of Muhammad himself. This is like Ibn Ishaq, is it? Eighth century or so? Yeah, so there's a guy called Ibn Ishaq who lives at the end of the eighth century
这是一个有着各种各样答案的问题。在一个极端，有些人认为传统记载完全值得信赖；而在另一个极端，有些人认为基本上我们对他的生平一无所知。事实上，甚至还有人认为他根本不存在。其原因在于，本质上，如果我们想要一份关于穆罕默德生平的叙述性记录，我们就依赖于那些首次被写下来，或者至少是得以保存并被写下来的文本。它们的年代大约在穆罕默德本人生活年代的两个世纪之后。这就像伊本·伊斯哈克（Ibn Ishaq）那样吗？大约8世纪左右？是的，有一个叫伊本·伊斯哈克的人生活在8世纪末，
and he gets kind of redacted by a guy called Ibn Hisam. And that's the version that we have. That's the earliest kind of narrative account. So the question is, what is the relationship of those accounts of his life to the historical Muhammad? But there are fragments, aren't there, from the time? So I've got a couple of them here.
他的一些内容被一个叫伊本·希沙姆（Ibn Hisham）的人进行了删节和整理。这就是我们所拥有的版本。这是最早的叙述性记录。所以问题是，这些关于他生平的记载与历史上的穆罕默德之间是什么关系？但确实有一些碎片证据来自那个时代，对吧？我这里就有几个。
There's a Syriac fragment from 636. Many villages were ruined with killing by the Arabs of Muhammad. So that's from within the sort of Roman world. There's a guy called Thomas the Presbyter, who again mentions the Arabs of Muhammad, 640. And then the most famous one is from the 660s so that's we're talking about what what's that about 30 years after Muhammad conventionally said to have died now this is by an Armenian bishop and he tells the story the sons of Ishmael there's a guy whose name was Muhammad a merchant he taught
有一个公元636年的叙利亚语残篇：“许多村庄被穆罕默德的阿拉伯人屠杀并摧毁。”所以这来自罗马世界内部。有一个叫普雷斯顿·托马斯（Thomas the Presbyter）的人，他也提到了穆罕默德的阿拉伯人，时间是640年。然后最著名的一个来自660年代，我们说的是……那是穆罕默德按常规说法去世大约30年之后。这段文字出自一位亚美尼亚主教，他讲述了这个故事：以实玛利的子孙们，有一个人名叫穆罕默德，是个商人，他教导
them to recognize the God of Abraham especially because he was learned and informed in the history of Moses. He told them, love only the God of Abraham, go and seize the land which God gave you to your father Abraham. No one will be able to resist you in battle because God is with you. So those are sources that appear to allude to the Muhammad that we know, but they're written from outside the Muslim tradition. So these are guys who are maybe hundreds of miles away. There is one that seems to be written during Muhammad's own lifetime. And so if that's the case, then Muhammad is the only founder of a great religious tradition of whom that can be said. Well, that's a fascinating point. So in other words, Muhammad is far from Muhammad being, well, okay, we can talk about
他们认识亚伯拉罕的真主，特别是因为他博学多才，了解摩西的历史。他告诉他们：“只爱亚伯拉罕的真主，去夺取真主赐给你们祖先亚伯拉罕的土地。没有人能在战场上抵抗你们，因为真主与你们同在。”所以，这些是似乎在暗指我们所知的穆罕默德的来源，但它们是从穆斯林传统外部撰写的。这些人可能远在数百英里之外。不过，似乎有一份是在穆罕默德有生之年撰写的。如果真是这样，那么穆罕默德就是伟大宗教传统中唯一一位可以这样说的创立者。这是一个引人入胜的观点。换句话说，穆罕默德远非穆罕默德……好吧，我们可以讨论
the sources about Muhammad, but what's clear, he's not unusual. I mean, Jesus, there are virtually no sources from the life of Jesus, I think. No, there are no sources from Jesus' life, but there are sources. So we have Paul's letters that are written a decade or so after, and then the Gospels are written a few decades after that. The problem is, is that we don't have the equivalent of Gospels. We don't have the equivalent of narrative lives of the prophet until much later. So it would be analogous to the kind of Gnostic Gospels that are being written around 200 A.D. And no one looks at those and thinks that they are a kind of authentic account of what happened in first century A.D. Judea. So that's the question. But having said that, yes, we do have these kind of early sources that clearly, I mean,
关于穆罕默德的来源，但显然，他并不罕见。我的意思是，关于耶稣，几乎没有任何来自耶稣生平的来源，我想。不，没有来自耶稣生平的来源，但确实有来源。我们有保罗的书信，它们写于大约十年后，然后福音书写于几十年后。问题在于，我们没有相当于福音书的文献。直到很晚以后，我们才有相当于先知叙事传记的东西。所以，这就类似于大约公元200年左右撰写的那些诺斯替派福音书。没有人会看着那些书，认为它们是对公元1世纪犹太地发生事情的真实记录。所以这就是问题所在。话虽如此，是的，我们确实拥有这些早期的来源，它们显然……
it seems to me, I can't imagine how anyone really can argue that Muhammad didn't exist. Yeah. He clearly did. These early texts, I mean, this is pretty solid evidence for it. And as I say, we have this one source called the Doctrina Jacobi, and it describes how Saracens, Arabs, led by a prophet, have invaded Roman Palestine and defeated the Romans. And it's hard to think who this is a reference to. It doesn't name Muhammad, but it's hard to think who this is referring to, if not Muhammad. But there is a problem and there are two problems with it one is that it's dated to 634 and the tradition as you as you said is that Muhammad
在我看来，我无法想象怎么会有人真正争辩说穆罕默德不存在。是的。他显然是存在的。这些早期的文本，我的意思是，这是相当坚实的证据。正如我所说，我们有一个名为《雅各布的教义》（Doctrina Jacobi）的来源，它描述了由先知率领的撒拉逊人、阿拉伯人如何入侵了罗马巴勒斯坦并击败了罗马人。很难想象这指的是谁。它没有点名穆罕默德，但很难想象除了穆罕默德之外，这还能指的是谁。但这里有一个问题，而且有两个问题：一个是它的年代被定为634年，而正如你所说，传统认为穆罕默德
dies in 632 so how do we square that the other is that it describes Muhammad leading an invasion and the Muslim tradition is absolutely clear that he did not do that that he dies before the invasion of Palestine which is the first target there's probably a good way of answering that though isn't that tom which is that well i mean one good way of answering it would be he's still alive and he's leading the invasion but another one would be that the guy who's who's uh what's it called the teaching of jacob or whatever yeah that jacob or whoever it is is a jacob who's writing it is that right is that his name it's complicated it's okay well whoever it is i mean who cares who it is whoever he is, is a Jacob who's writing it. Is that right? Is that his name? It's complicated. Okay, well, whoever it is. I mean, who cares who it is?
死于632年，我们该如何调和这一点？另一个是它描述穆罕默德领导了一场入侵，而伊斯兰传统非常明确地表明他没有这样做——他在入侵巴勒斯坦（这是第一个目标）之前就去世了。不过，回答这个问题可能有一个好方法，汤姆，不是吗？那就是，一种很好的回答方式是：他还活着，并且正在领导入侵；而另一种回答方式则是，那个撰写者——那个叫什么来着，“雅各布的教义”还是什么的，是的，那个雅各布或者无论他是谁——一个名叫雅各布的人在撰写它，是这样吗？是叫这个名字吗？这很复杂。好吧，不管他是谁——谁在乎他是谁？
Whoever it is, he's repeating a garbled story that he's heard in an age when information travels slowly and incompletely, and he might just have got it wrong, or his interlocutor might have got it wrong. I think there's a more interesting explanation, which is that the prophet, the biblical figure who is named more than any other in the Quran is Moses. And I've already mentioned that the Hidra, the exile, the exodus. I mean, that's what Moses does. He leads his people from Egypt to the promised land.
不管他是谁，他只是在重复一个面目全非的故事，这个故事是他在一个信息传播缓慢且不完整的时代听来的，他可能只是弄错了，或者他的对话者弄错了。我认为有一个更有趣的解释，那就是：在《古兰经》中，被提及次数超过任何其他人的圣经人物是摩西。我之前已经提到过希吉拉（Hidra），也就是流亡、出埃及。我的意思是，这就是摩西所做的事：他带领他的子民从埃及走向应许之地。
And that's essentially what Muhammad does when he leads his people from Mecca to Medina. The other thing for which Moses is famous is that he dies before the children of Israel enter the promised land. And essentially, this is a problem if you were casting Muhammad as the new Moses, which I think is basically what's going on. So you can see how that tradition would be erased. And you start to construct a tradition in which Muhammad is described as like Moses dying before his people enter the promised land. And this focuses attention on something that also that's very interesting, which is that it's clear that Palestine, Jerusalem, the Holy Land, the sense of belonging to this biblical tradition, going back through Jesus, through Moses, to Abraham, is incredibly important. And the fact that Palestine is the first target of the invasions doesn't seem to be a coincidence. So I think that what happens is that
这本质上也就是穆罕默德带领他的子民从麦加走向麦地那所做的事情。摩西闻名的另一件事是，他在以色列人进入应许之地前就去世了。本质上，如果你把穆罕默德塑造成新的摩西，这就是一个问题——而我认为这基本上就是正在发生的事情。所以你可以看出，那段传统为什么会被抹去。然后你开始构建这样一种传统：穆罕默德被描述成像摩西那样，在自己的人民进入应许之地前就去世了。这就将注意力集中在另一个非常有趣的事情上，那就是很显然，巴勒斯坦、耶路撒冷、圣地，以及对这种圣经传统的归属感——通过耶稣、摩西一直追溯到亚伯拉罕——是极其重要的。巴勒斯坦是入侵的第一个目标，这一事实似乎并非巧合。所以我认为发生的事情是：
if you look at these early sources, you can kind of work out a way in which there is an emphasis on the Holy Land that in due course comes to fade because the Arab Empire comes to embrace a vast range of territories. And essentially what begins perhaps as a movement that is more Jewish, that is more ethnocentric, that is more focused on a Holy Land, comes to be more Christian, comes to be more universalizing. And what emerges as Islam, and I think that Islam is not kind of something that's served up on a plate by Muhammad to his followers and they then take it out. I think it's something that emerges over the course of the Arab conquests and the decades that follow, that it emerges to provide the new rulers of this vast empire with an explanation for why God has given them this
如果你审视这些早期来源，你可以理出一条线索：其中对圣地有着某种强调，这种强调随着时间的推移而逐渐淡化，因为阿拉伯帝国最终囊括了广阔的领土。本质上，最初可能是一个更具犹太色彩、更具民族中心主义、更侧重于圣地的运动，逐渐变得更具基督教色彩，变得更具普遍化。最终浮现为伊斯兰教的东西——我认为伊斯兰教并不是穆罕默德端在盘子里交给他的追随者、然后他们再拿出去推广的东西。我认为它是随着阿拉伯征服进程以及随后的几十年而逐渐显现出来的，它的出现是为了给这个庞大帝国的新统治者们提供一个解释：为什么真主赋予了他们这个帝国，以及为什么他们配得上继续统治它。这就是为什么我没有问，因为我认为我们应该营造一种语境感，因为如果我们理解了当时正在发生的事情，我们就能更全面地理解穆罕默德、对巴勒斯坦的运动以及所有其他事情。通常情况下，我想你会在书中读到，它们会说，你知道的，那是罗马，那是波斯，然后突然在7世纪中期，几乎是从天而降，从沙漠中，这些没人知道的家伙带着这个刚刚凭空冒出来的新伊斯兰教讯息爆发了，这是一场巨大的冲击，诸如此类。而我总是认为，这并不是一个对所发生事情很有说服力或引人入胜的解释。
empire and why they deserve to continue ruling it. That's why I didn't ask because I think we should give a bit of a sense of context because I think we can understand Muhammad and that movement to Palestine and all the rest of it more completely if we understand what's going on. Quite often I think you'll read in books will say you know it's Rome and it's Persia and then suddenly in the mid-7th century almost out of nowhere out of the desert these guys who no one knew about erupt with this new message of Islam that has just come out of nowhere and it's this great shock and all the rest of it and I was always thinking that's not very um not a very persuasive or or indeed compelling account of what happened.
因为我认为实际发生的事情要有趣得多。所以你有……如果你想想这两个超级大国。所以你研究过这个，对吧？是的，我研究过。所以你研究过这个。那是什么时候？80年代？90年代，90年代。所以你当时在研究什么？
Because I think what happened is actually much more interesting. So you've got, I mean, if you think about these two superpowers. So you studied this, didn't you? Yeah, I did. So you studied this. So that was what, 80s? 90s, 90s. So what were you studying?
你当时被告知了什么？嗯，我选修了一门在牛津很有名的课程，因为它是第一门允许你阅读翻译文本的课程。所以它是一门名为《查士丁尼和穆罕默德时代的近东》的课程。这是牛津历史学位的一部分——尽管这对那些听播客却不关心牛津历史的人来说没说多少东西。但这是第一门这样的课程。在此之前，如果你不会读原典，你就永远无法在牛津学习相关内容。而拜占庭的一位伟大历史学家，我想是德米特里·奥博伦斯基（Dmitry Obolensky），曾说过：“这完全不合理，因为没有人来到牛津就能直接阅读亚美尼亚语、中世纪亚美尼亚语之类的语言。”所以他们同意你可以修读这门课程。于是你修了这门课程，讲的是查士丁尼、穆罕默德以及——西方帝国已经灭亡时期的近东世界。罗马正在变成拜占庭。
What were you being told? Well, I did a course that was famous at Oxford because it was the first course where you were allowed to read things in translation. So it was a course called The Near East in the Age of Justinian and Muhammad. And it's part of going to Oxford kind of history law, not that that's saying very much to people who don't care about Oxford history who listen to the podcast. But it was the first course. Previously, you could never do stuff at Oxford if you couldn't read the original sources. And a great Russian history of Byzantium, I think it was, Dmitry Obolensky, said, you know, this is completely unreasonable because no one's going to arrive at Oxford and be able to read like Armenian, medieval Armenian or something. So they agreed that you could do this course. And so you did this course, which was Justinian and Muhammad and the world of the Near East at the time of the fall of – the Empire in the West has fallen. Rome is becoming Byzantium.
它将成为这个崭新的伊斯兰世界。而我所学到的——所以对我来说，这是最有趣的经历之一——这也是我为什么真的很想研究这个主题的原因，实际上，因为这是我经历过的最有趣的智力冒险之一，如果我可以这样称呼它的话。因为，当然，你首先会阅读关于穆罕默德的传统记载，然后就会发现整套史学，而即使在当时，这也是极其充满争议的。
It's going to become this new Islamic world. And what I learned – so for me, it was one of the most interesting – and it's why I really wanted to do this subject, actually, because it's one of the most interesting, and it's why I really wanted to do this subject actually, because it's one of the most interesting intellectual adventures, if I can call it that, that I've kind of been on. Because, of course, you first read the traditional accounts of Muhammad, and then there's this whole historiography, which even then was incredibly controversial.
所以当时有一个叫约翰·万斯伯勒（John Wansborough）的美国伊斯兰学者，我们读了他的东西，他基本上说：“你知道的，传统的版本是错的。”我的意思是，汤姆，你会了解所有这些——《古兰经》、伊斯兰教其实比所有人想象的都要晚出现，阿拉伯征服是先发生的，这东西是从中东演变出来的，然后——是的，完全正确——它源于……你知道的，一旦他们拥有了阿拉伯帝国，他们基本上就需要为此发展一种信条——我的意思是，我真的把这大大简化了。然后他的两个学生，正如你所知的，帕特里夏·克罗恩（Patricia Crone）和迈克尔·库克（Michael Cook）
So there was a guy called John Wansborough, American scholar of Islamlam and we read that and and he basically said you know the traditional version is wrong i mean you'll know all this tom that the quran that islam is a later creation than everyone thinks that the arab conquest kind of happened first and this is emerges out of the middle east and that yes exactly um that it emerges out of um you know once they've got the arab empire then they need to develop a creed for it basically i mean i'm really simplifying it and then two of his students as you will know patricia kroner and michael cook
接过了这一衣钵，提出了一个论点，写了一本名为《哈加尔主义》（Haggarism）的书。在这本书中，他们基本上认为：伊斯兰教最初是一场犹太弥赛亚运动，后来当他们决定抛弃犹太性时，才发展出了某种阿拉伯成分。但在90年代，这也极具争议。我的意思是，我想当我学习它时，我们读过这个，但随后它已经稍微被否定了，作者们自己也曾表示：“嗯，实际上，也许确实曾有过一个穆罕默德，也确实有过《古兰经》。”所以，我认为实际上，据我从史学中能够看出的——我绝不是这方面的专家——人们已经发现了雕刻品等等，碑文。关于历史上的穆罕默德，比人们想象的要有更多的证据。你同意这一点吗？不。嗯，我认为史学进程的本质是，你拥有这两个非常极端的极端：
took that on and it got came up with this argument called called book called haggarism where they basically argued that you know islam had begun as a jewish messianic movement and then developed a kind of arab component later on when they decided to ditch the jewishness but that was very controversial even in the 90s i mean i think when i was studying it we read that but then to kind of slightly it had already been slightly repudiated the authors themselves had said well actually maybe there was a was a Muhammad and there was the Quran. So, and I think actually, as far as I can tell from the historiography, and I'm not an expert
穆罕默德不存在。《古兰经》是在7世纪和8世纪编纂的。这特别是一些前置理论的观点。然后你拥有传统的叙述，其中麦加就像当时的迪拜，香料商队以及所有这类东西，还有一场资本主义危机。基本上，这是1970年代对7世纪阿拉伯的一种倒投影。我认为这两者都已经逐渐退出了历史舞台。但我觉得浮现出来的是一种尝试：将穆罕默德作为圣人置于晚期古代世界之中。
in this by any means, people have found engravings and so on, inscriptions. There's more evidence than people thought for a historic Muhammad. Would you agree with that? No. Well, I think essentially the process of the historiography is that you have these two very radical extremes.
而晚期古代是一个……是的，富有而圣洁的人，非常富有而圣洁的人。富有而圣洁的人。但我得告诉你我们应该说些什么，汤姆。这是富有而圣洁的人，因为这是一个正在经历惊人创伤的世界，对吧？我的意思是，你有……
Muhammad didn't exist. The Quran was compiled over the 7th and 8th century. That's particularly the ones preposition. And then you have the traditional account in which Mecca is kind of the Dubai of its day, spice trains and all that kind of stuff. And there's a crisis for capitalism. And basically, it's a 1970s back projection onto 7th century Arabia. And I think that both of those have kind of fallen by the wayside. But I think what's emerged is an attempt to situate Muhammad within the world of late antiquity as a holy man.
所以对于那些不熟悉晚期古代这个极其有趣时期的人来说，你知道的，税基正在崩溃。因为瘟疫。6世纪曾发生过一场大瘟疫。这场毁灭性的瘟疫，人们说它夺去了世界三分之一、甚至一半人口的生命。这可能是夸张，但在某些地方或许并非如此。我认为直到最近，历史学家才真正给予它应有的核心地位。
And late antiquity is a period where... Yeah, rich and holy men, very rich and holy men. Rich and holy men. But I'll tell you what we should say, Tom. It's rich and holy men because this is a world going through an astonishing trauma. Generally, isn't it? I mean, you've got...
关于这一点相对于阿拉伯正在发生的事情而言，有趣的是它不成比例地打击了城市。你能在阿拉伯的记载中看到相关内容。因此，瘟疫被描述为由精灵（jinn）射出的箭。这有点像《伊利亚特》中阿波罗向希腊人降下密集的箭雨。但这些箭只有当你从沙漠中出来时才会射中你。所以也许在那里，有一个关于正在发生事情的有趣线索：新月沃地的人口与广袤沙漠中人口之间巨大的不平衡，第一次开始缓和下来了。然后在此之上，你还有一场大战。
So for people who aren't familiar with this incredibly interesting period of late antiquity, you know, tax bases are collapsing. Because of plague. There's been this massive plague in the 6th century. This devastating plague that people say, you know, has killed a third, half of the world. It may be exaggeration, but maybe in certain places not. Which I think only recently historians have really given the centrality it deserves.
是的，这场大规模的战争。所以，我的意思是，我们在谈论什么？罗马和波斯基本上作为两个超级大国存在了多久，700年？所以他们瓜分了那个世界。500年，萨珊王朝和罗马人。
And the interesting thing about that relative to what's happening in Arabia is that it hits cities disproportionately. And you have Arab accounts about it. So the plague is described as arrows shot by the jinn. So a bit like Apollo raining arrows on the Greeks in the Iliad. But these arrows only hit you if you come out of the desert. So perhaps there, there's a kind of interesting clue to what's going on, that for the first time, there's this kind of, you know,
不过波斯更广泛地说，我想，还要追溯得更远。所以他们发动了一场类似于三十年战争风格的冲突，从602年一直持续到628年，我想是这样，其间局势剧烈起伏。我的意思是，这是一种《权力的游戏》风格的战争，波斯人似乎所向披靡。他们攻占了这些省份，包括耶路撒冷。是的，埃及、巴勒斯坦等等，这场战争中波斯人似乎势如破竹，他们占领了这些省份，包括耶路撒冷、是的，埃及、巴勒斯坦等等，这些省份一直是罗马世界的中心，然后
the huge imbalance of population between those in the Fertile Crescent and those in the deserts beyond is starting to ease down. And then you have the Great War on top of that. Yeah, this massive war. So, I mean, what are we talking about? Rome and Persia have been the two superpowers for basically, what, 700 years? So they've divided that world between. 500 years, the Sasanians and the Romans.
希拉克略（Heraclius），这位非凡的罗马将军，掌握了皇帝的权柄。是的，嗯，他掌握了帝国的权柄，然后他展开了一系列战役，你知道的，他在战役中度过冬天，这真的很棒，可以说是具有开创性的。他基本上把波斯人击退了，重新征战并收复了所有这些领土。在那个时候，人们经常说——他的传记作者和写过他的人说——要是他死了就好了。要是他就在那个时候死掉，他就会被铭记为有史以来最伟大的罗马皇帝之一。但当然，他没有死。接下来发生了什么？突然间，这些家伙出现在了沙漠中。
Well, Persia more generally, though, I suppose, going back even further. So they launched this sort of 30 years war style from 602 to 628, I think it is, which seesaws incredibly. I mean, it's sort of Game of Thrones style war, which the Persians seem to carry all before them. And they capture these provinces. Including Jerusalem. Yeah, Egypt, Palestine, and so on, war which the persians seem to carry all before them and they capture these provinces including jerusalem yeah egypt palestine and so on that have been central to the roman world and then
他们夺取了罗马人曾收复的所有省份，而波斯人之前一直在花钱雇佣阿拉伯人，基本上让他们作为沿边境的缓冲区。所以当时有两个政权，对吧？加萨尼王朝（Ghassanids）和拉赫姆王朝（Lakhmids）。由于两个帝国都资金短缺，他们本质上是将巡逻边境的业务特许经营给这些阿拉伯人。当罗马人被驱逐出巴勒斯坦时，那些阿拉伯人就没有资金进账了。而这恰好是传统将穆罕默德以及这种庞大军队等待接管的涌现置于其中的时期。现在，可能的情况是，在驱逐波斯人之后，你在巴勒斯坦所面对的基本上类似于法国的越南（二战后），法国人卷土重来试图恢复他们的统治。但本质上，他们的威望已经荡然无存。那里只有极少数的法国骑兵。因此，后来的传统将其描绘为一场伟大的入侵，而实际上可能只是一种缓慢的内爆：先前被雇为雇佣兵的阿拉伯人基本上搬了进去，他们不再需要罗马人，直接接管了那里。所以，这完全可能是当时正在发生的事情。但同样真实的是，汤姆，难道不是吗？阿拉伯世界与罗马和波斯世界之间的互动，比人们通常认为的要多得多。所以常见的版本是：存在着一层沙幕，
heraclius this extraordinary roman general takes the reins of the emperor yeah well he takes the reins of the empire and then he goes on these campaigns where he you know he he he spends winter on campaign which is great really sort of groundbreaking. And he basically casts the Persians back, reconquers all this territory. And at that point, people often say, his biographers and people who've written about him say, if only he died. If only he died right then, he would be remembered as one of the absolute all-time great Roman emperors. But of course, he doesn't die. And what happens next? Suddenly, these fellows will appear out in the desert.
这些家伙在这层沙幕后面潜伏了数百年，无人问津，然后突然爆发，成为了某种不可思议的新力量，有点像是《权力的游戏》中多斯拉克人（Dothraki）抵达维斯特洛（Westeros）那样。但实际情况根本不是这样的。他们一直在与罗马人进行贸易。他们一直在为他们工作。人们一直在两地之间往返。我的意思是，
And they take all the provinces that the Romans had captured back and the Persians are paying Arabs to essentially kind of serve as buffer zones along the borders. So there's two regimes, aren't there? The Hassanids and the Lachmans. And because both empires are short of money, essentially they're franchising out the patrolling of the frontier to these Arabs. When the Romans get kicked out of Palestine, those Arabs have no money coming in. And this is exactly the period at which tradition places Mohammed and the emergence of this kind of huge army waiting to take over. Now, it's possible that essentially what you have in Palestine after the expulsion of the Persians is kind of like French Vietnam, you know, after the Second World War the Persians is kind of like French Vietnam,
他们全都心知肚明。这就是那些思想——宗教思想的来源，我的意思是，那里有基督徒。有阿拉伯基督徒，对吧？确实有。所以，在过去几十里，这成为了试图理解穆罕默德可能是谁或什么的中心焦点：试着将他置于那个世界中，置于波斯与罗马竞争的世界中，同时也是一个充斥着基督教、犹太教甚至祆教元素的密林般的世界，并且也许——仅仅是也许——还包含着在其他地方已经消逝、但在巴勒斯坦之外的沙漠中依然流传的传统。因为如果你看看关于穆罕默德的传统记载——这些传记在9世纪到10世纪的过程中，随着你离那个时代越远，变得越来越详尽——它们显然在被添加无关的信息。有点像亚瑟王传奇并不能真正告诉你任何关于晚期罗马不列颠或后罗马不列颠背景的信息。同样，这些关于穆罕默德的传记也没有告诉你太多关于……它们并不是真正扎根于一个可识别的晚期古代世界中。（那里）有零星的基督徒，零星的……麦地那处理过一个犹太部落。有对希拉克略的零星提及。但总的来说，这不是一个充满了我们能识别为晚期古代特征的丰富提及的世界。所以，吸引人的地方在于尝试将穆罕默德置于一个能将他理解为7世纪初人物的语境中，而不是将他塑造成一个基本上是为了解释和证明穆斯林统治者、乃至后几个世纪的广大穆斯林需要他去做的事情而被构建出来的人。所以挑战就在于：你是否要彻底抛弃伊斯兰传统？你是否只借鉴那些源自他生前或其生命结束后几十年内的文本？或者说，穆斯林传统中是否存在某些你可以借鉴并据此构建模型的元素？我认为，有一个核心问题真正构成了整个问题的基础。而且这只对非穆斯林来说是个问题。所以对穆斯林来说，解释《古兰经》从何而来并不是问题：它来自真主。这就是穆斯林信仰的精髓。
you know, after the Second World War, that the French are coming back in trying to resurrect their rule. But essentially, their prestige has been demolished. And there are very few kind of French troopers there. And essentially, what is cast by the later tradition as a kind of great invasion may just be a kind of slow implosion in which Arab people, Arabs who previously had been employed as mercenaries, essentially kind of move in and don't need the Romans and they just take it over. So it's possible that that is what is going on. But it's also true, isn't it, Tom, that there's much more interplay between the Arab world and the Roman and Persian worlds than people often think. So the common version, which is there's this sort of veil of sand
但如果你不是穆斯林，你就必须解释《古兰经》究竟是从哪里来的。万斯伯勒关于《古兰经》在8、9世纪逐渐形成的论点，我认为已经被彻底推翻了。我认为很明显，《古兰经》与一个名叫穆罕默德的人有关。尽管它的汇编需要时间，但很显然，正是那些先知的话语共同构成了《古兰经》。因此，《古兰经》确实为历史上的穆罕默德所生活的世界提供了证据。当然，你仍然必须解释这些文本是如何以及为什么会出现的。好吧，汤姆，你为什么不休息之后再讲呢？
behind which these guys have been lurking for hundreds of years and no one's cared about, and suddenly they erupt, and they're this incredible new force, sort of like the Dothraki arriving in Westeros to go out to our Game of Thrones. But that's not really the case at all. They've been trading with the Romans. They've been working for them. People have been traveling back and forth. I mean,
好吧，因为我只是想说明这是一个问题，因为除了传统的穆斯林说法之外，我们没有关于《古兰经》来源的其他叙述。我记得当我参观纽约大都会艺术博物馆关于拜占庭与早期伊斯兰教的展览时，我对此类问题感触颇深。拜占庭展厅里的标签、那种文化分类都非常世俗化。因此，对基督教实践的描述并非来自基督教的观点。它是非常非常客观、非常非常世俗的。然后当你走到伊斯兰展厅时，那里收藏着早期《古兰经》文本。
they all knew. And that's where the ideas, the religious ideas, I mean, there are Christians. There are Arab Christians, aren't there? There are. So this is, over the past decades, this has been the main focus of trying to understand who or what Muhammad might have been, is to recognize, is to try and situate him in that world, in the world of Persia and Roman rivalry, but also a world that is absolutely teeming with Christian, with Jewish, even with Zoroastrian elements, and perhaps, just perhaps, with traditions that have faded elsewhere, but are still current in the deserts beyond Palestine. Now, because if you look at the traditional accounts of Muhammad, these biographies that over the course of the 9th into the 10th
那里有一个关于《古兰经》的布告牌。上面写着《古兰经》是被启示的——你知道的，是真主通过天使传达给穆罕默德的启示。事情就是这样。没有任何语境。没有试图去解释：对于一个不相信真主、不相信天使、甚至不相信穆罕默德是真主先知这一特定事实的人来说，这可能意味着什么。同样，你在非常非常著名的学术著作中也能找到这一点。有一本书是由一位杰出的古代史学家格伦·鲍尔索克（Glenn Bowersock）写的，书名叫《伊斯兰教的熔炉》（The Crucible of Islam），里面充满了对宗教传统的精彩分析。我的意思是，他对波斯攻陷耶路撒冷及罗马人收复该城的传统记载做出了非常精彩的怀疑主义解读。但当他写到穆罕默德时，他写下了这样一句话：“加百列带给穆罕默德的启示发生在麦加。”他没有对此进行阐述。他没有……他只是说穆罕默德从天使那里得到了启示，然后就不了了之了。好吧，这有点像我当年选修那门课时的情景——当我选修《查士丁尼和穆罕默德时代的近东》这门课时……
century, they become more and more elaborate the further away you go. So they're clearly being, you know, extraneous information is being added to it. A bit like Arthurian romances don't tell you anything really about the context of, you know, late Roman Britain or post-Roman Britain. So likewise, these biographies of Muhammad do not tell you very much about they don't they're not really grounded in a recognisable world of late antiquity. You know, there's the odd Christian, there's the odd, you know, there's a tribe of Jews who get dealt with at Medina. There's kind of mentions of Heraclius. But by and large, it's not a world that is rich in mentions that we can recognize as being late antique. So the fascination is to try and situate Muhammad in a context that makes sense of him as an early 7th century figure, rather than as someone who has been constructed basically to explain things and to justify things that the
世纪，离得越远，它们就变得越详细精细。因此很明显，你知道的，无关的信息被添加进去了。这有点像亚瑟王传奇并不能真正告诉你任何关于，你知道的，晚期罗马不列颠或后罗马不列颠背景的信息。同样，这些关于穆罕默德的传记也没有告诉你太多，它们并不是真正建立在一个可识别的晚期古代世界中。你知道的，偶尔有基督徒，偶尔有，你知道的，有一支犹太部落在麦地那被处理。有对希拉克略的某种提及。但总的来说，这不是一个充满了我们能识别为晚期古代特征的引用的世界。因此，人们着迷的地方在于试图将穆罕默德置于一个能让他作为7世纪初人物而合情合理的背景中，而不是把他当作一个基本上是为了解释事物和证明事物合理性而被构建出来的人物，这些事物是
Muslim rulers and indeed Muslims more generally in the later centuries need him to do. And so that's the challenge is, do you jettison the Islamic tradition completely? And do you only draw on texts that originate within or in the decades after his life? Or are there elements within the Muslim tradition that you can draw on and construct a model for? And there is one key question, I think, which really underlies the whole problem. And it's only a problem for non-Muslims. So for Muslims, it's not a problem to explain where the Quran comes from. It comes from God. That's the essence of what a Muslim believes.
穆斯林统治者，甚至更广泛地说后来的几个世纪里的穆斯林需要他去做的事情。所以这就构成了挑战：你是完全抛弃伊斯兰传统吗？你是否只利用那些起源于他生前或他生后几十年内的文本？或者穆斯林传统中是否存在你可以借鉴并构建一个模型的元素？我认为有一个核心问题，它确实是整个问题的基础。而且这只是非穆斯林的问题。因此对于穆斯林来说，解释《古兰经》从何而来并不是一个问题。它来自上帝。这正是穆斯林信仰的本质。
But if you're not a Muslim, you have to explain how it was that where does the Quran come from? The ones for thesis that the Quran emerged over the eighth and ninth century has been conclusively disproved, I think. I think it's clear that the Quran is associated with someone called Muhammad. And although it takes time for it to be compiled, it's clear that there are prophetic utterances that together will constitute the Quran. So therefore, the Quran does provide, I think, evidence for the kind of world
但如果你不是穆斯林，你必须解释《古兰经》是怎么来的，《古兰经》究竟源自何处？我认为，关于《古兰经》是在八九世纪才逐渐形成的这种论点已经被确凿地推翻了。我认为很明显，《古兰经》与一个叫穆罕默德的人有关。尽管它的汇编需要时间，但很明显，正是这些先知言论共同构成了《古兰经》。因此，我认为《古兰经》确实为我们了解历史上的穆罕默德所生活的那个
in which the historical Muhammad was living. But of course, you still have to explain how and why it is that these texts emerge. Well, Tom, why don't you do that after the break? Well, because I just want to set up that this is a problem because there is no other account we have of where the Quran comes from except the traditional Muslim one. And I remember being struck by what a problem this is for secular historians, where I went to an exhibition in the Metropolitan Museum in New York about Byzantium in early Islam. And the labels, the kind of cancer in the Byzantine
世界提供了证据。但当然，你仍然必须解释这些文本是如何以及为什么会出现的。好吧，汤姆，你为什么不在中场休息后接着说呢？好吧，因为我只是想先指出这是一个问题，因为除了传统的穆斯林说法之外，我们没有关于《古兰经》来源的其他记载。我记得当我参观纽约大都会艺术博物馆关于拜占庭和早期伊斯兰教的展览时，我被这对于世俗历史学家来说是多么严重的一个问题给震撼到了。标签，拜占庭
rooms were all very secular. So the descriptions of Christian practices were not from a Christian point of view. It was very, very objective, very, very secular. Then you got to the Islam room, and there was a collection of early Korans. and there was a kind of billboard talking about the Korans. And it said the Koran was revealed, you know, the revelations that were given to Mohammed by by God and that came to him by the angel. And that was it. There was no context. There was no attempt to explain what this might mean for someone who doesn't believe in God or doesn't believe in angels or even doesn't believe in the specific fact that Muhammad is a prophet of God. And likewise, this is something that you will find in books by very, very reputable academics. So there's a book written by Glenn Bowersock, a very distinguished ancient historian who wrote a book called The Crucible of Islam, which is full of brilliant analysis of religious traditions. I mean, he does a brilliantly kind of
展厅里的那些解说非常世俗化。因此，对基督教习俗的描述并非来自基督教的视角。它是非常非常客观的，非常非常世俗的。然后你来到了伊斯兰展厅，那里收藏了早期的《古兰经》，并且有一个关于《古兰经》的某种布告牌。上面写着《古兰经》是受启示的，你知道的，真主通过天使将启示赐予了穆罕默德，事情就是这样。没有任何背景。没有任何尝试去解释这对于一个不相信上帝、不相信天使、甚至不具体相信穆罕默德是真主的先知这一事实的人来说可能意味着什么。同样，你在许多声誉极佳的学者所写的书中也会发现这一点。比如，著名古代史学家格伦·鲍尔索克（Glenn Bowersock）写过一本名为《伊斯兰教的熔炉》（The Crucible of Islam）的书，里面充满了对宗教传统的精彩分析。我的意思是，他对
sceptical account of the traditional accounts of the fall of Jerusalem to the Persians and the way that the Romans take it back. But when he's writing about Muhammad, he's got this bold line, the revelations that Gabriel brought to Muhammad came in Mecca. Doesn't elaborate on that. Doesn't, he's asking, you know, he's saying Muhammad gets it from an angel and leaves it at that. Well, this is a bit like when I did, so when I did that course, The Near East in the Age of Justin and Muhammad,
传统关于耶路撒冷陷落于波斯人以及罗马人收复该城的说法做出了非常精彩的怀疑论述。但当他写到穆罕默德时，他有这样一句直白的断言：加百列带给穆罕默德的启示发生在麦加。没有对此作任何详细阐述。没有，他在说，你知道的，他在说穆罕默德从天使那里得到了启示，然后就不了了之了。好吧，这有点像我当年选修的那门课程，查士丁尼和穆罕默德时代近东史
I remember saying to my tutor, so not about the Islamic element, but actually about icons. There was a point at which a source says an icon repelled an army or something. And I said, but surely I don't, I'm not meant to believe that, am I? I mean, I don't believe icons can repel armies. And I suppose it's the same, but a more fraught problem, I think.
我记得我对我的导师说，不是关于伊斯兰教的成分，而是关于圣像。有那么一个地方，史料说一幅圣像击退了一支军队之类的。我说，但当然我不用、我不应该去相信这个吧，对吧？我的意思是，我不相信圣像能击退军队。我想这是一样的，但我觉得这是一个更令人棘手的问题。
I mean, you don't have a problem as a historian saying that an icon can't repel an army, or you don't believe that Jesus could do miracles, or you don't believe in every word of the Acts of the Apostles. But it is more difficult for a historian to say that of early Islam because you're worried about giving offence, effectively. Effectively, but also, I think it's not just offence, but I think upsetting people for whom the Qur'an is the revelation that's come from God. And if you start putting it on the slab of historical inquiry and dissecting it
我的意思是，作为一个历史学家，你说圣像不能击退军队，或者你不相信耶稣能行神迹，或者你不相信《使徒行传》的每一个字，你不会有什么问题。但对历史学家来说，要对早期伊斯兰教这样说是更困难的，因为你实际上担心会冒犯别人。实际上，但我也认为，这不仅是冒犯，而且我认为这会打扰那些对他们来说《古兰经》是来自上帝的天启的人。如果你开始把它放在历史探究的砧板上进行剖析，
and chopping it up and, you know, against other things, then obviously that, that, that's a stressful thing to do. But I think that's not a reason not to do it because it, I'm sure,
把它切碎，你知道的，与其它事物作对比，那么显然这、这、这是一件压力很大的事情。但我认为这不是不这样做的理由，因为我确信，
you know, I mean, I know for a fact that most Muslims are happy to accept that if you're not a Muslim, then of course you have to arrive at an alternative explanation for where the Quran comes from. And I think it's an expert And I think there are explanations for where it comes from. And I think they're not divorced from Mohammed. So we'll come to that after the break. Let's come back after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
你知道的，我的意思是，我很清楚，大多数穆斯林乐于接受这样一种观点：如果你不是穆斯林，那么你当然必须对《古兰经》的来源得出另一种解释。我认为这是一个专家……而且我认为对它的来源是有解释的。而且我认为它们与穆罕默德并不是毫无关系的。所以我们休息之后再来谈这个。让我们休息后回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about the life of Muhammad and early Islam. And Tom Holland, you posed before the break this question about the Quran
这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，并告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外集以及优先购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余音》。我们正在讨论穆罕默德的一生和早期伊斯兰教。汤姆·霍兰，你在中场休息前提出了关于《古兰经》的问题，
and where the Quran comes from. So there are Quranic fragments, aren't there, which have been carbon dated. So there is one in Birmingham, I think it is. Let me get my notes. The Birmingham fragment is no later than the 640s or so. There's one in Tübingen in Germany, 650s or 660s. So we know that elements of the Qur'an... But you see, even they are problematic because that's the latest date.
以及《古兰经》从何而来。所以有一些《古兰经》残篇，对吧，它们经过了碳十四测年。所以其中有一份在伯明翰，我想是的。让我看一下我的笔记。伯明翰残篇不晚于公元640年代左右。德国图宾根有一份，是650年代或660年代的。所以我们知道《古兰经》的某些成分……但你看，即使这些也是有问题的，因为那是较晚的日期。
But the earlier dates are well into the 6th century, so before supposedly muhammad has been born so that's that's a problem uh and the obvious suggestion would the obvious solution to that is that it's it's the manuscript you know it's the parchment that's being tested not the ink so yeah this could be fragments the the problem is whenever you were trying to find absolute kind of solidity absolute certainty in this field is it's like wading through through sinking sands and every time you think you found kind of solid ground you found it giving it away again it gives away again but
但较早的日期甚至可以追溯到6世纪，也就是在穆罕默德据称出生之前，所以这、这是一个问题，呃，显而易见的建议，或者说显而易见的解决办法是，它是手稿，你知道的，是羊皮纸被检测，而不是墨水，所以是的，这可能是残篇，问题是无论你什么时候试图在这个领域找到绝对的坚实基础、绝对的确定性，这就像在流沙中跋涉，每当你以为自己找到了坚实的土地，你就会发现它再次坍塌了，它再次坍塌了，但是
historians of the quran generally believe don't they that the quran was um as it were, sort of enshrined. It was set in stone, as it were, later. There were bits of it that possibly come from... There were different versions of the same passage, for example, at different points in the text, that the text was edited at some point after Muhammad's death. That must be the case there are probably as as many um different versions of of how and why the quran emerged the way it did as there are historians writing about it um in fact i thought that this would come up so i armed myself with um a copy of a book called the quran in its historical
《古兰经》的历史学家通常认为，《古兰经》曾经是……怎么说呢，被奉为经典。可以说，它是在后来被定格的。其中有些部分可能来自……例如，在文本的不同地方，同一段落有不同的版本，文本在穆罕默德去世后的某个时候被编辑过。情况肯定如此，关于《古兰经》如何以及为何以它呈现的那种方式出现，可能有多少个不同的版本，就有多少个撰写关于它的历史学家，嗯，事实上，我以为这会提到，所以我给自己武装了一本名为《历史语境中的古兰经》的书，
context um and it's the the it's an introductory essay by the great scholar of early Islam, Fred Donner, who's at Chicago. I'll read it. It's a paragraph, but I think it's worth reading because this is the perspective of an absolutely accepted, standard-bearing scholar of this subject. And he opens it by saying, Quranic studies as a field of academic research
呃，它是芝加哥大学杰出的早期伊斯兰教学者弗雷德·唐纳（Fred Donner）写的一篇导言性文章。我来读一下。这是一个段落，但我认为值得一读，因为这是该领域一位完全被接受的、标准的学者的观点。他在开篇时说，作为学术研究领域的《古兰经》研究，
appears today to be in a state of disarray. Those of us who study Islam's origins have to admit collectively that we simply do not know some very basic things about the Quran, things so basic that the knowledge of them is usually taken for granted by scholars dealing with other texts. They include such questions as, how did the Quran originate? Where did it come from? And when did it first appear? How was it first written? In what kind of language was, is it written? What form did it take? Who constituted its first audience? How is it transmitted from one generation to another, especially in its early years? When, how, and by whom was it codified? Those familiar with the Quran and the scholarship on it will know that to ask even one of these questions immediately plunges us into realms
今天似乎处于混乱状态。我们这些研究伊斯兰教起源的人不得不集体承认，关于《古兰经》，我们确实对一些非常基础的事情一无所知，这些事情是如此基础，以至于研究其他文本的学者通常认为这些知识是理所当然的。其中包括这样一些问题：《古兰经》是如何起源的？它来自哪里？它是什么时候首次出现的？它最初是如何被书写的？它是用什么语言书写、曾经书写或正在书写的？它采用了什么形式？谁构成了它的第一批受众？它是如何一代接一代地传下去的，尤其是在它的早期？它是什么时候、如何以及由谁被编纂的？熟悉《古兰经》及其相关学术研究的人都会知道，提出哪怕其中一个问题，也会立即把我们带入严重不确定的领域，并且有可能引发激烈的辩论，这可以说是轻描淡写的说法。是的。所以，因为关于穆罕默德生平的传统叙事是我们拥有的唯一版本，从你质疑这一点或偏离这一点的那一刻起，本质上，你就必须为一个可能发生的事情构建一个模型。你在拼凑碎片。你正试图拼凑一个缺失了大部分的拼图，甚至连这个拼图原本长什么样你都无法确定。因此，毫不奇怪的是，关于《古兰经》如何以及
of grave uncertainty and has the potential to spark intense debate, which is, you know, putting it mildly. Yes. So because the traditional account of Muhammad's life is the only version that we have, the moment you question that or you move away from that, essentially, you have to construct a model for what might have happened. You're putting fragments together. You're trying to put together a jigsaw puzzle in which large bits are missing, and you can't even be certain what the jigsaw puzzle originally looked like. And so it's not surprising that basically there are as many different accounts of how and
为什么会出现，这与穆罕默德有什么关系，以及穆罕默德与晚期古代的语境有什么关系，基本上有多少个学者在撰写关于它的文章，就有多少种不同的说法。我认为，这正是使得对其的研究具有独一无二的挑战性的原因。我的意思是，这就是为什么基本上我为此花费的五年时间里，我的脑子一直在痛。但当你写完时，你的书是《剑的阴影》，对吧？你知道，一本引人入胜的书。你做了一个电视节目或者两个节目，我想。是两个节目吗？
why the Quran might have emerged and how that might relate to Muhammad and how Muhammad might relate to the context of late antiquity as there are scholars writing about it. And that is what makes this, I think, uniquely challenging to study. I mean, that's why I basically, the five years I spent on this, my brain ached the whole time. But when you finish, so your book is The Shadow of the Sword, isn't it? You know, fascinating book. And you did a TV program or two programs, I think. Was it two programs?
只有一个。只有一个，作为配套节目。你知道，这是一个极其丰富的主题，你显然在创作时觉得非常有趣，尽管它是一个挑战。但你从这个过程中走出来时，必定有一种感觉，尽管是暂时的，你——我把你架在火上烤，问你，你认为这个故事是什么？你会怎么说？好吧，我认为穆罕默德是一个商人。
Just one. Just one, accompanying it. You know, incredibly rich subject that you clearly had great fun doing, although it was a challenge. But you must have come out of it with a sense, however provisional, that you – I put you on the spot and said, what do you think the story is? What would you say? Okay, I think that Muhammad was a merchant.
所以我想传统的这部分是真的。你提到的那个非常早期的资料告诉了我们这一点。他视自己为亚伯拉罕先知世系中的一员。所以他大概是从这里得知的，因为犹太教在麦加或阿拉伯半岛到处都是。这里有一大堆各种各样的思想，也许一会儿我们会谈到这一点，也许一会儿会谈到这一点，呃，我们可以确定的事情，我、我认为他进行了希吉拉，即出走，我认为这种移民的理想对于他的历史和对于呃《古兰经》来说是至关重要的，所以我认为，这就是，我认为呃雅特里卜是他建立社群的地方，
So I think that part of the tradition is true. We're told that by this very early source that you mentioned. He sees himself as standing in the line of Abrahamic prophets. So he's probably got that because Judaism is floating around Mecca or the Arabian Peninsula. There's a sort of stew of ideas come to that in a minute perhaps come to that in a minute um things that we can be certain about he i think he he engages in a hydra an exodus i think the the ideal of the kind of emigration is is fundamental to his history and to uh to the quran so i think that's that's i think that um yathrib is where he sets up a community
这既是因为雅特里卜在当代资料中被主教或其他任何人反复提及，他们没有任何特殊的理由去为此撒谎、去歪曲这一点，也是因为呃在呃最早的传记中，关于穆罕默德的穆斯林传记中，保存了通常被称为《麦地那宪法》的片段，这显然是非常早期的文本。那是一种国家建设类的练习。是的，国家建设。所以我认为雅特里卜显然是核心。正如你所说，确实有一些铭文似乎与发现的某些关于此事的穆斯林记载相吻合。我认为这个社群
and that's both because yathrib is is repeatedly mentioned in the contemporary sources by you know bishops or whoever who have no particular reason to to lie about that to distort that um and also because um in uh the earliest biographies, Muslim biographies of Muhammad, there are preserved fragments of what's conventionally called the Constitution of Medina, which is clearly very early texts. That's a state building kind of exercise. Yes, state building. So I think that Yathrib is clearly central. As you said, there are inscriptions that do seem to kind of tie in with some of the Muslim accounts about this that have been found. I think that this community
对扩张很感兴趣。我认为它有一种后圣经的愿景，它对传播这种愿景很感兴趣。我认为穆罕默德领导了对巴勒斯坦的入侵。我认为他去世了，并且我认为他的遗体被带回了麦地那。然后我认为他基本上被遗忘了一会儿。我们也许会稍后探讨其中的原因。但随后的问题是，如果他正在领导、如果他正在建立这个充满圣经热忱与知识的社群，那么他对圣经的知识是从哪里来的？至少这些圣经传统是从哪里来的？如果按照传说所说，他在麦加长大，那是一个完全异教的城市，你知道的，距离基督徒和犹太人所在的地方有千里之遥，
was interested in expanding. I think it had a kind of post-biblical vision that it was interested in spreading. I think Mohammed led the invasion of Palestine. I think that he died and I think his body was taken back to Medina. And I think that he then essentially got forgotten for a bit. And we'll come to the reasons why for that perhaps a bit later. But the issue then is if he's lead if he's founding this this biblically enthused informed community um where does his knowledge of of the bible come from what will be at least these biblical traditions if as the tradition says he's growing up in mecca which is an entirely pagan city you know a thousand miles
在我看来，穆罕默德在麦加（或者我们现在称之为麦加的地方）长大的故事，就相当于基督徒说耶稣是童贞女的儿子，在这两种情况下，这都是为了保护神圣的载体免受指责——在穆罕默德的例子中是神圣本质，在耶稣的例子中是神圣本质，免受以下指责：即这些都是骗局，耶稣是某个百夫长的儿子或者别的什么，玛丽是用完全正常的方式怀孕的，或者对于穆罕默德而言，他是受到他所生活的世界背景的影响。
away from where christians and jews are and it seems to me that the story of of muhammad growing up in mecca or what the place we now call mecca is the equivalent of christians saying that jesus is the son of of a virgin that in both cases it's an attempt to insulate the vehicle of the divine in the case of muhammad the the you know the essence of the divine in the case of jesus from the of the divine in the case of Jesus, from the charge that these are frauds, that Jesus is the son of a centurion or something, that Mary got pregnant in a perfectly normal manner, or Muhammad, that he's influenced by the context of the world that he's living in.
之所以必须防范这一点，是因为它可能暗示这些传统、《古兰经》中的这些元素可能来自于穆罕默德出生的更广阔世界的背景。现在，这就是历史与信仰之间的紧张关系短兵相接的地方。因为如果你是一个信仰者，那么它当然来自上帝，这是你信仰的本质；但如果你不是一个信仰者，那么你当然会说，看这段文本，所有这些元素，它们显然来自基督教、犹太教，通常甚至是更古老的传统。然后你必须问自己，穆罕默德是如何以及为什么吸收它们的？所以其中一个词，显然是其中的关键事情之一，就是麦加，
And the reason why that has to be guarded against is because it might imply that these traditions, these elements within the Quran might have come from the context of the broader world in which Muhammad has been born. Now, this is where the tension between history and belief kind of locks horns. Because if you you're a believer then of course it comes from god that's that's the essence of your belief but if you're not a believer then of course you know you're going to say well look at this text you know there are all these elements they they clearly come from christian jewish often you know even older traditions and then you have to ask yourself how and why did they did muhammad come to to absorb them so one of the words obviously the key things in this is mecca
是这个概念，即麦加在哪里适合，因为麦加是一个贸易城镇，它有集市，有市场，人们去那里，但我们怎么知道的呢？好吧，无论如何，这是我们的指导假设。现在，诸如帕特里夏·克罗内（Patricia Crone）这样的历史学家在《古兰经》中指出并引发疑问的事情之一是，穆罕默德在《古兰经》中谈到他的敌人是那些种植葡萄、枣椰树、饲养绵羊和奶牛之类的人，基本上麦加人可能并没有这些东西，这是一个问题，对吧？是的，这是一个问题。
is the idea is is what what where mecca fits in because mecca is a is a is a trading town um it has fairs it has markets people go but how do we know that well um this is a this is our guiding assumption anyway. Now, one of the things that people like historians like Patricia Croner pointed to in the Koran that they say they have raises questions is that Muhammad talks in the Koran about his foes being people who have, they grow, you know, vines, They have date palms. They have sheep and cows and things like that, that basically people probably didn't have in Mecca, which is a problem, right? Yes, it is a problem.
所以一些历史学家说，这表明关于这一切都发生在麦加的传统假设一定是错误的，如果他们有所有的这些绵羊和奶牛，它一定发生在更北的地方，这将使它更接近巴勒斯坦的世界和罗马世界，这些思想可能就是从那里来的。特别是橄榄。而提及的那种橄榄是
So some historians say, well, that suggests that the traditional assumption that all this is happening in Mecca must be wrong, that if they've got all these sheep and cows, it must be happening further north, which would bring it closer to the world of Palestine and the Roman world where the ideas could be coming from. And particularly olives. And the kind of olive that's referred to is
只生长在地中海附近，离地中海近得多的地方。所以，我认为这是一个问题。而且我认为，杰拉尔德·霍丁（Gerald Hawting）在一本划时代的书中论证过，在《古兰经》中被称为“穆什里克人”（mushrakin）的人，他们实践着被称为“希拉克”（shi'aq）的东西，这是一种将神灵或或许天使与上帝联系起来的做法。这就是他们的罪过。而传统认为这是异教崇拜，他们是在崇拜阿拉伯异教的神和女神。
only grown kind of within the, much closer to the Mediterranean. So that, I think, is a problem. And I think also the fact that it was argued by Gerald Horting in a kind of epical book that people who are called the mushrakin in the Quran, who practice what's called shi'aq, which is kind of associating deities or perhaps angels with God. And this is their crime. And the tradition is that this is paganism, that they are worshipping gods and goddesses from pagan Arabia.
但霍丁的论点是，实际上穆罕默德或先知，或者《古兰经》的任何作者，称他们为偶像崇拜者，就像新教徒可能称天主教徒为偶像崇拜者一样。你知道，新教徒可能会称天主教徒为异教徒。这并不意味着新教徒和天主教徒不是基督徒。他们显然是的。所以这个论点是，实际上《古兰经》所见证的本质上是关于圣经中上帝的一场争论，围绕着诸如天使与上帝的正确关系在多大程度上、是什么之类的问题展开的，而这正是让穆罕默德、先知或无论他是谁感到关切的事情，
But Horting's argument is that actually Muhammad or the prophet or whoever the author of the Quran is, is calling them idolaters in the way that Protestants might call Catholics idolaters. You know, Protestants might call Catholics pagans. That doesn't mean that Protestant Catholics aren't both Christian. They clearly are. So the argument is that actually what the Quran bears witness to is essentially an argument about the biblical God that's over issues like, to what extent, what is the proper relationship of angels to God? And that this is what Muhammad is, or the prophet or whoever he is,
所以这里有一个亚伯拉罕诸教的世界，这本质上是其中的一场争论，而不是将亚伯拉罕诸教引入一个人们在崇拜某种其他异教偶像的世界，是的，本质上是这样，这就引出了一些人们询问的问题，我们的一些常客以及我们的自由派人士史蒂芬·延森（Stefan Jensen）询问了穆罕默德的信息与基督教神学，萨斯克里特（Sascript）询问了犹太教与伊斯兰教之间的相似之处，所以对于任何穆斯林或非穆斯林来说，显而易见的是，伊斯兰教处于——好吧，它处在与犹太教和基督教大致相同的宗教宇宙中，我们可以这么说。所以对穆斯林来说，亚伯拉罕起作用，
is getting exercised by. So there's a world of abrahamic religion and that this is an argument within that basically rather than it rather than importation of a abrahamic religion into a world where people are worshipping pagan idols of some other kind yes essentially um and so that raises a couple of questions that people asked about so some of our regularists and one of our liberalists stephan yensen has asked about muhammad's message and christian theology and sascript has asked about similarities between judaism and islam so it is perfectly obvious to anybody muslim or non-muslim that islam is is in well it's in the same sort of religious universe shall we say as as Judaism and Christianity. So Muslims, Abraham plays a part,
摩西起作用，耶稣起作用，尽管穆斯林不相信他是上帝的儿子。所以你认为，首先，你认为伊斯兰教，你认为它是从……我的意思是，有一种观点认为它来自一个被称为犹太基督徒的派别，这对于我们的一些听众来说会显得非常晦涩。好吧，对穆斯林来说，伊斯兰教提供了一个模板，以此来判断
Moses plays a part, Jesus plays a part, although Muslims don't believe he was the son of God. So do you think, well, first, do you think Islam, do you think it's come out of, I mean, there's an argument that's come out of this sect, which are called the Jewish Christians, which is a very sort of, will seem very obscure to some of our listeners. Well, for Muslims, Islam provides a template by which to judge whether
犹太教和基督教是否被腐蚀了。因为耶稣、摩西、亚伯拉罕都是穆斯林。他们都宣讲同样的信息。犹太经文和基督教经文不再符合这一点的程度，反映了它们被腐蚀的程度。所以对穆斯林来说，你是跨越时间向后审视的，这显然不是历史学家通常使用的方法。对于历史学家来说，你拥有一个包含犹太和基督教元素的文本主体，这显然意味着它们必定来自犹太和基督教来源。现在，犹太和基督教元素
Judaism and Christianity are corrupted. Because Jesus, Moses, Abraham are all Muslim. They all preach the same message. And the degree to which Jewish scripture and Christian scripture no longer accords to that is a reflection of the degree to which they've been corrupted. So for Muslims, you judge kind of backwards through time, which obviously is not a technique that historians generally use. For a historian, the fact that you have a body of text with Jewish and Christian elements obviously means that they have to come from Jewish and Christian sources. Now, the Jewish and Christian elements
在《古兰经》中往往让那些在犹太和基督教传统中长大的人感到相当困惑。它们似乎反映了往往相当古老的视角。因此，例如关于耶稣神性的争论，可以追溯到基督教的初期。在《古兰经》中，你一再发现神学论战的元素，这些论战在世界其他地方基本上已经得到了解决。这就是为什么很难知道这些元素来自何处。但我会说，对于一个非穆斯林、一个怀疑论历史学家来说，这似乎完全是可以解释的。
within the Quran are often quite confusing to those brought up in Jewish and Christian traditions. And they seem to reflect perspectives that are often quite ancient. So the argument, say, about the divinity of Jesus is one that goes right the way back to the beginnings of Christianity. And again and again in the Quran, you find elements of theological battles that elsewhere in the world had basically been settled. That's why it's so hard to know where these elements are coming from. But I would say that seems completely, to a non-Muslim, to a sceptical historian, that would seem completely explicable.
这是罗马世界的边缘地带。这是一个世界，其余的世界一直饱受瘟疫的摧残，帝国遭受了严重的创伤，叙利亚、沙漠等等一直是圣人和教派繁荣发展的地方。在我看来，在……我们说的是什么时候，6世纪末什么的。
This is a peripheral part of the Roman world. It's a world that has been, the rest of the world has been blighted by plague The empire has suffered serious traumas Syria, desert and so on Has been a place where holy men and sects And things have always flourished It would seem not weird at all to me That at the end of the What are we talking about, the end of the 6th century or whatever.
7世纪初，是的。是的，有各种各样的思想在流传，在君士坦丁堡的人看来可能非常过时，比如耶稣实际上不是上帝的儿子。但这些都是极其严重的异端邪说。而且它们混淆了犹太和基督教传统，在晚期古代的过程中，本质上发生的是拉比、主教和教会神父挖掘战壕、将人们从无主之地拉回来的过程，而你似乎在《古兰经》中看到的是一个文本，这些战壕已被抹去，这些不同的传统再次混合和交融，但是
Beginning of the 7th, yeah. Yeah, there are all kinds of ideas floating around that might seem very old fashioned to people in Constantinople, like Jesus was not actually the son of God. But these are massively, massively heretical. And also they confuse confuse jewish and christian traditions and what's happened over the course of late antiquity essentially is a process of of both rabbis and bishops and church fathers digging trenches and pulling people back from the no man's land and what you seem to get with the quran is a text where these trenches have been erased and these different traditions are mixing and mingling again um but
你不得不问，你知道，这些传统是如何以及为什么突然变得生动起来的，我的意思是，这就像，你知道，这就像在神学中发现了一个侏罗纪公园，你知道的，这些、它们本不应该存在，所以……还有一个来自——“有礼貌的鹦鹉”（名字很精彩）的问题：穆罕默德真的识字吗？所以这是传统，
you've got to ask well you know how and why are these traditions suddenly kind of coming to life i mean it's like you know it's like discovering a kind of jurassic park of of theologies you know these these they shouldn't really be around um so and there's a question from uh polite parrot splendidly named was muhammad really literate so this is the tradition um there's a verse in the quran that implies that he might be but equally it can be reinterpreted it and what you do get through the quran is a massive respect for for texts yeah um the whole of creation is described as a text um and it it may be that you know that there are kind of people scholars have found echoes of the dead sea scrolls for instance in the quran you know are people digging up these scrolls you know
《古兰经》中有一节经文暗示他可能会，但同样地它可以被重新解读，而在《古兰经》中你确实看到的是对文本的极大尊重，是的，整个创造被描述为一个文本，并且可能……学者们在《古兰经》中发现了死海古卷的回音，例如，你知道，人们是在挖掘这些古卷吗？你知道，他们在远处的沙漠中寻找古卷吗？我的意思是这太难了，我的意思是你会觉得自己带着这种问题误入了丹·布朗的领地，但这很难知道，而且你知道，我认为本质上你不得不举手投降，并且说，我的意思是，我的设想会是，你知道，这是一个在某种程度上似乎失去了早晨的世界，它是末世论的，这是《古兰经》的另一个特点，那就是，是的，它是非常末世论的，它是一个末日世界。它感觉像是末日。真正构筑这个世界的两大强权，
are they finding scrolls in the the deserts beyond i mean it's so difficult i mean you feel that you're straying into dan brown territory with this kind of but it's very difficult to know and you know i think essentially you have to kind of throw your's very difficult to know and you know i think essentially you have to kind of throw your hands up and say i mean i think i mean i think i mean my scenario would be you know it's a very it's a it's a world that seems to have lost its mornings to some extent which is apocalyptic and that's the other thing about the quran is that yeah it's very apocalyptic it's an ap world. It feels like the end of days. The two great powers that have really structured this world,
不仅仅是像任何人能记住的那么久，我的意思是，绵延数百年的这两大强权正处于某种崩溃状态。有一场人们可能还记得的瘟疫。它正在持续。他们还记得那个。是的，我的意思是……所以世界末日感觉就在穆罕默德身边，正如你在你那出色的概述中所说，他是一个富裕女商人的业务代理人，他在旅行，那是后来的事，但我们知道他是个商人，
not just for as long as anyone can remember, I mean, stretching back hundreds of years, these two great powers are in kind of meltdown. There's been a plague which people can probably remember. It's ongoing. They can remember that. Yeah, I i mean so the end of the world feels like it's around muhammad is as you said in your brilliant sort of overview he's a business agent for a well-to-do business woman he's traveling that that's late but we know he's a merchant
让我们想象一下他正在旅行，他听到了很多不同的思想，他到了40岁，你知道，要么他接受了神圣的天启——如果你是穆斯林，你就会相信这一点；或者如果你是一个怀疑论历史学家、世俗历史学家，你会认为他把这一切都整合在一起，所有这些流传的思想。他确信自己是一位先知。我的意思是，我认为毫无疑问。
let's imagine that he is he's traveling he's hearing a lot of different ideas he gets to 40 and you know either he receives a divine revelation, which you believe if you're a Muslim, or if you're a sceptical historian, secular historian, you think he puts all this together, all these ideas that are floating around. He's convinced that he is a prophet. I mean, I think there's no doubt about that.
我想他一定坚信自己是一位先知。显而易见的是，他周围的人认为他是一位先知。但同样有趣的是，他周围的时代也认为他是一位先知。但也有趣的是，时机刚刚好。市场是存在的，因为，你知道的，阿拉伯人一直是一支聪明、机动的骑兵，但从未被统一过。他们花了很多时间互相征战。他们有效地把自己当作罗马人和波斯的雇佣兵。突然间，罗马人和波斯人崩溃了。如果阿拉伯人能够振作起来，围绕某种能让他们超越分歧的事物团结起来，
I think he must believe that he's a prophet. And what's clear is that the people around him think he's a prophet. But there's also, what's interesting is that the time around him think he's a prophet. But there's also what's interesting is that the time is right. The market is there because, you know, the Arabs have always been brilliant, mobile sort of cavalry, but never been united. Spent a lot of time fighting each other. They've been hiring themselves as effectively for mercenaries, for the Romans and the Persians. Suddenly the Romans and the Persians have fallen apart. And if only the Arabs can kind of get their act together and unite around something that makes them transcend their
你知道，世界就是他们的囊中之物。我想情况可能比这更复杂。所以我想一些阿拉伯人可能直接受到了穆罕默德教导的启发，但我也认为其他人可能只是，你知道的，他们只是搬进来并拿走他们能得到的东西。但你为什么不呢？我的意思是，巴勒斯坦就在那里。当然。伊拉克也是。叙利亚也是。你只是搬过去，然后突然间埃及沦陷了，你发现你拥有了……这就像过熟的鸡肉从骨头上脱落下来。这只是，你知道的，你只是把它捡起来。
differences, you know, the world is their oyster. And I think it may be even more complicated than that. So I think that some of the Arabs may be directly inspired by Muhammad's teaching, but I think others may be, you know, they're just kind of moving in and taking what they can get. But why wouldn't you? I mean, Palestine is right there. Absolutely. And so is Iraq. So is Syria. And you kind of just move and suddenly then Egypt's fallen and you find that you've got, it's like kind of overboiled chicken falling off the bone. It's just, you know, you're just picking it off.
然后你必须解释这是如何发生的，因为这是一个没有上帝的意愿就不会发生任何事情的时代，而关于阿拉伯对新月沃地及其他地区统治的早期岁月，最迷人的是，穆罕默德随后消失了——所以他没有被提及，他没有出现在硬币上，似乎没有人谈论他。然后发生的是，你经历了一场内战，基本上人们在为帝国而战。谁将宣称上帝的衣钵？上帝已经将自己确立为上帝的最爱、上帝的副手。
And then you have to explain how this has happened, because this is an age where nothing happens without god wanting it to happen and what's what's fascinating about the early years of of um the arab rule of of the fertile crescent and beyond is that muhammad then vanishes so he he does not get mentioned he doesn't appear on he doesn't appear on coins nobody seems to talk about him and then what happens is that you have a civil war and basically people are fighting over the empire. Who's going to claim the mantle of God? God's established himself as God's favorite, God's deputy.
你有一个叫伊本·祖拜尔（Ibn al-Zubayr）的人，我们被告知他占据了沙漠某处的上帝之殿。内战中的其中一个人是一个叫伊本·祖拜尔的家伙。当代资料告诉我们，他来到了南方的某个地方，那里有穆斯林。他们的圣所就在那里，并在那里生活。所以它没有具体说明在哪里，但就在沙漠的某个地方。而这个圣所在一场围攻中被毁了，
And you have a guy called Ibn al-Zubayr who we're told occupies the house of God somewhere in the desert. And one of the guys in the civil war is a bloke called Ibn al-Zubayr. And we're told by a contemporaneous source, he came to a certain locality in the south where they're the Muslims. Their sanctuary was and lived there. So it doesn't specify where it was, but somewhere in the desert. And this sanctuary gets destroyed in a siege uh
伊本·祖拜尔继续战斗，圣所再次被毁，但在某个时候，伊本·祖拜尔在伊朗的一个盟友发行了一枚硬币，硬币上首次提到了阿拉伯文文本中的穆罕默德。那么这大约是什么日期？这大约是685-686年。好的。通过这样做，伊本·祖拜尔能够为自己宣称神圣的制裁，因为他能够说：我正在追随上帝先知的足迹。通过这样做，他立即提升了他的宗派角色的尊严，基本上。与此同时，在巴勒斯坦、叙利亚，特别是耶路撒冷，还有另一个人叫阿卜杜勒·马利克（Abdul Malik）。阿卜杜勒·马利克注意到了这一点，并认识到，宣称拥有这件衣钵是很棒的。他将自己塑造成——所以他建造了岩石圆顶清真寺，
ibn al-zabaya fights on uh the sanctuary gets destroyed again um but at some point one of ibn al-zabaya's allies in iran issues a coin and on that coin is the first mention of Muhammad that you get in an Arabic text. So what date is this roughly? This is about 685-686. Okay. And by doing this, Ibn al-Zubayr is able to claim a divine sanction for himself because he's able to say, I am following the footsteps of the prophet of God. And by doing that, he immediately dignifies his kind of sectarian role, basically. Meanwhile, there's another guy in Palestine, in Syria, and specifically in Jerusalem, called Abdul Malik. And Abdul Malik picks up on this and recognizes that, you know, it's great to lay claim to this mantle. And he casts himself as, so he builds the Dome of the Rock,
真正幸存下来的第一个初具规模的穆斯林建筑。上面有非常反三位一体的铭文，因此反对耶稣是上帝的儿子、三位一体等观念。宣告穆罕默德为这位独一神的先知，并且他开始发行硬币，呃，上面提到了穆罕默德，而阿卜杜勒·马利克将自己塑造成——上帝的副手，哈里发——并且看起来，我的意思是，一个极其自信的人，相当坚信自己是一个与穆罕默德本人同样重要的人物。但他赢得了内战，击败了伊本·祖拜尔，对阿拉伯帝国建立了某种普遍的统治。
the first kind of emergent Muslim building to have survived, really. And there are these inscriptions on it that are very anti-Trinitarian, so opposed to the idea that, you know, Jesus is the son of God, that one is three, three is one. Proclaiming Muhammad as this one god's prophet uh and he starts to issue coins as well that um that that mentioned muhammad and abdul malik casts himself as um the deputy of god the caliph uh and seems you know i mean a man of of immense self-confidence, pretty convinced that he is as significant a figure as Muhammad himself is. But he wins in the civil war, defeats Ibn al-Zubayr, establishes a kind of a universal rule over the Arab empire.
正是在阿卜杜勒·马利克的统治下，你开始看到大规模地宣告穆罕默德为上帝的先知。似乎还有《古兰经》的编纂。似乎还有最初将我们现在称为麦加的地方宣告为麦加，宣告为上帝圣所的所在地。所有这一切，都是从阿卜杜勒·马利克的统治开始的，你可以开始看到某些
And it's under Abdul Malik that you start to get the massive proclamation of Muhammad as a prophet of God. It seems the codification of the Quran. It seems the initial proclamation of the place that we would now call Mecca as having been Mecca, as having been the site of the sanctuary of God. And all of this kind of package, it's from the reign of Abdul Malik that you can start to see something
我们认为是伊斯兰教的东西正在涌现，并采取了此后一直保持的形式。但这也是一个时代，汤姆，当时会有还记得穆罕默德的人，对吧？我的意思是，如果他们老了，他们就非常老了。所以我们谈论的是，你刚才说的是680年代左右吗？是的。
that we will recognize as Islam emerging and taking the form that it's had ever since. And this is at a time, though, Tom, when there would have been people who could remember Muhammad, right? I mean, if they were old, they were very old. So we're talking about, you're talking about what, 680s, did you say? Or so? Yes.
所以如果穆罕默德在632年去世，有可能是有些老人，或者某些人肯定能记住他的人的儿子存在，但同样地他们可能非常少，因此这使得人们能够……你知道的，你比平时拥有了一块更空白的画布，你知道的，这就是——阿拉伯人在这个阶段没有把事情写下来，或者如果他们写了，也没有保存下来，他们没有写叙事，所以这些都是叙事，这是一个基本上传统几乎可以从零开始建立的时代，我的意思是，你知道的，著名的例子是基督徒出现在圣地，并将所有这些地方识别为灌木丛，你知道的，摩西遇到燃烧的灌木丛的地方，或者，你知道，这座房子是圣彼得住过的地方，诸如此类。犹太传统也发生了同样的事情。琐罗亚斯德教传统也发生了同样的事情。似乎没有理由说明这一切不会发生在后来成为穆斯林的传统上。因为事实是，《古兰经》中首次提到麦加要到8世纪中叶。即使在那时，它也被放置在伊拉克的月牙沃地的某个地方。而上帝之殿的位置，显然至关重要，据推测是穆罕默德前往进行希吉拉的地方，据推测是伊本·祖拜尔要去的地方。但我们被告知它被毁了。它被毁了两次。所以如果它被夷为平地，重建它的任务
So if Muhammad died in 632, it's plausible there could be some old people would, or there would be sons of people who certainly could have remembered him but equally they're probably very few um and so that therefore enables people to kind of you know you have a slightly blanker palette than you might otherwise have done um you know and this is this is the the arabs at this stage are not writing stuff down or if they are it hasn't survived they're not writing accounts so it's these are all accounts uh and this is an age when um basically traditions can be started almost from scratch i mean this is you know the famous example is christians turning up in the holy land and kind of identifying all
或许把它放在另一个地方，放在一个让伍麦叶王朝（阿卜杜勒·马利克出身的家族）更容易找到的地方，就会变得容易得多。我不认为这是一种蓄意的欺骗。这有点像奥林匹斯山在定名为我们现在所称的奥林匹斯山之前，被许多山脉所识别
these places as the bush you know the bush where Moses, you know, the burning bush or, you know, this house is where St. Peter lived or whatever. The same thing happens with Jewish traditions. The same thing happens with Zoroastrian traditions. And there seems no reason why the same thing can't have happened with what becomes Muslim traditions. Because the truth is, is that the first mention of Mecca isn't until the middle of the 8th century. And even then it's placed somewhere in the Fertile Crescent in Iraq. And the location of the House of God, which is clearly crucially important, is presumably where Muhammad went on Hijra from, is presumably the place that Ibn al-Zabara is going to. But we're told it gets destroyed. It gets destroyed twice over. So if it's been leveled, the task of rebuilding it
或者卡米洛特（Camelot），你知道的，卡米洛特有许多不同的地点。但有许多地方、许多不同的传统，也许与穆罕默德有关。也许穆罕默德确实与后来成为麦加的地方有某种联系。但本质上，这是一个时代，从穆罕默德的有生之年到随后的50年，这些几十年是一个一切皆有可能的时期，混凝土尚未凝固，那个塑造和雕塑故事的人……所以我想某个地方有一个问题，你知道，是否有一个相当于圣保罗的人？我的意思是，基本上，阿卜杜勒·马利克就相当于圣保罗和君士坦丁堡，他是那个将穆罕默德确立为一位上帝先知的人，而这位上帝也对阿卜杜勒·马利克以及阿拉伯人对世界帝国的统治给予了认可，
and perhaps locating it somewhere else in a place that the Umayyads, the family from which Abdul Malik comes from, becomes much easier. And I don't think that it would be a kind of deliberate fraud. It's just rather like Olympus was a place that kind of lots of, identified with lots of mountains before it settled on the mountain we now call Olympus
但他也将穆罕默德的故事、他与神龛的关系的故事、以及他与《古兰经》的关系的故事进行美化，使其能够持久并流传下来。早期的记载被抹去了。在我们……我们可能已经谈了太久了，但在我们结束之前，
or Camelot, you know, lots of locations for Camelot. But there are lots of places, lots of different traditions, perhaps associated with Muhammad. Perhaps Muhammad did have an association with the place that comes to be Mecca. But essentially, it's a time, these decades from, you know, the lifetime of Muhammad through the kind of 50 years that follow are a period where everything is up for grabs, and the concrete is not yet set, and the guy who shapes and molds the story. So I think there's a question somewhere about, you know, is there someone who's equivalent of St. Paul? I mean, basically, Abdul Malik is the equivalent of St.ul and constantine he's the person who is establishing muhammad as the prophet of a god who has also given his
让我们稍微谈谈穆罕默德后来的声誉。所以穆罕默德显然有……他是一个在历史上产生巨大回响的人物，不仅对穆斯林，对非穆斯林也是如此。我知道你有一些关于后来撰写关于穆罕默德的人的好例子。所以卡莱尔（Carlyle）我想是你的例子之一，对吧？好吧，在此之前，对于基督徒来说，他们并不认为穆罕默德是先知或不同宗教传统的创立者。他们认为他是一个分裂主义者。所以在但丁的作品中，这就是他的命运：他被判处被撕成碎片，重新组合，然后再被撕成碎片。汤姆，人们在什么时候停止将伊斯兰教视为某种……
sanction to the rule of abdul malik and and the arabs over the over the empire of the world um but who is also kind of canonizing the story of Muhammad, the story of his relationship to a shrine and the story of his relationship to the Quran in a way that will then endure and pass down. And the early accounts get erased. Before we, we've already talked for probably far too long, but before we come to an end,
基督徒、罗马人，他们在什么时候停止将伊斯兰教视为某种……因为起初他们显然认为伊斯兰教是一种奇怪的犹太异端。但他们在什么时候说，它是一个拥有丰富传统等各种东西的独立宗教？是的，在近代早期开始的时候。然后通过维多利亚时代，
let's just talk a little bit about Muhammad's reputation later. So Muhammad obviously has run, you know, he's a figure who has resounded through history, not just for Muslims, but for non-Muslims too. And I know you've got a couple of good examples of people who wrote about Muhammad afterwards. So Carlisle, I think, is one of your examples, isn't it? Well, before that, for Christians, they have no sense of Muhammad as a prophet or a founder of a different religious tradition. They see him as a schismatic. So in Dante, that's the fate. He's sentenced to be torn to pieces, reassembled and torn to pieces again. At what point, Tom, did people stop thinking of Islam as a sort of...
人们开始对穆罕默德着迷。所以正如你所说，卡莱尔写了一本关于他的传记，并将他奉为伟人的模范，是的，然后你也有其他的历史学家尝试采用“生平与时代”风格的方法——将穆罕默德置于那个时代的背景中，但正是在那里，你得到了他作为生活在麦加的商人的所有传统，麦加是一个伟大的商业城市等等诸如此类，这些随后被穆斯林学者采纳。所以某种意义上，今天穆罕默德的模式是一个相当西化的模式。当然，有很多穆斯林意识到了这一点，并希望回到最初的、你知道的，纯粹的经文方式，拿出脱漆剂……但这有一个精彩的描述，
Did Christians, sort of Romans, at what point did they stop thinking of Islam? Because at first they clearly thought of Islam as this sort of weird Jewish heresy. But at what point do they say, it's a religion in its own right that's got a rich tradition and all this sort of stuff? Yeah, beginning of the early modern period. And then through the Victorian period,
由一位名叫卡特·阿里（Kater Ali）的学者所作，他写了一本关于穆罕默德身后之名以及穆斯林和非穆斯林如何理解他的精彩书籍，书中谈到象征性书写的文本后来被字面化地阅读了，我认为这正是问题所在，关于穆罕默德有太多东西现在在穆斯林传统中被当作一种字面的、字面意义的历史叙事，然而事实上，在大多数伊斯兰教历史中，穆罕默德就是——你知道的，他是真主的挚爱，他是那个因此而被爱的人——而试图将他视为一个历史人物更像是一个西方项目。所以这里确实存在某种紧张关系，我认为这显然集中在西方国家，
people get fascinated by Muhammad. So as you say, Kalil writes a life of him and kind of enshrines him as the model of a great man yeah uh and and then you also have other other historians who who kind of try and do the life and times style approach so putting muhammad in the context of the age but that's where you get all the traditions of him as a merchant living and mecca as a kind of great merchant city and all this kind of thing um which then gets picked up by Muslim scholars. So there's a sense in which the model of Muhammad today is quite a westernized one. And there are lots of Muslims, of course, who recognize that and who want to go back to an original, you know, script away, get out the paint stripper um but there's a there's a brilliant description
这是对历史上的耶稣的探寻，对吧？非常相似，我的意思是，是的，你知道，试图将基督历史化，所以在某种程度上，整个传统是一个基督教传统，因为它是为了从历史角度理解耶稣和圣经而孕育的基督教传统。人们随后使用这些技术，将其应用于穆斯林传统，这就是为什么，难免地，我认为它可能会在穆斯林中引起反感，因为你应用的是一个外来的传统。我永远对你的能力感到敬畏，无论主题是什么，你都能天衣无缝地提出一个非常令人信服的论点，即这一切都可以追溯到你关于基督教传统的优秀著作《多米尼恩》（Dominion）。
of what they're doing by um a scholar called kater ali who's written a wonderful book about the afterlife of muhammad and the way that both muslims and non-muslims have understood him and it says about the text written symbolically came to be read literally and i think that's that's the problem is that there's so much about muhammad that gets is now taken as a kind of literary literal historical account in the muslim tradition whereas in fact it it for most of of of islamic history muhammad is that you know he's the beloved of god he's the the man who that's why he's loved um and the kind of attempt to see him as a historical figure is much more of a western project so there is a kind of tension there i think and it's one that obviously is focused in western
好了。我为你做了一次宣传。谢谢。要是能找到一种方法，把所有主题都和20世纪70年代哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）的第二任首相任期联系起来就好了。但是，当然，如果你什么时候开始写关于撒切尔夫人首相任期晚期和梅杰首相任期的书，我希望你会这样做。
countries it's quest for the historical jesus isn't it it's very not dissimilar i mean yes you know the attempt to historicize christ and so that whole tradition in a way is a kind of christian one because it's bred of the christian to make sense of Jesus and the Bible historically. And people then using those techniques, then apply it to the Muslim tradition, which is why, I mean, inevitably, I think it kind of can raise hackles among Muslims, because you're applying an alien tradition. I'm permanently in awe of your ability to, no matter what the subject, to seamlessly make a very convincing argument that it all comes back to your excellent book Dominion about the Christian tradition.
各个国家，这其实就是对历史上的耶稣的探寻，对吧？这非常相似。我的意思是，是的，你知道的，试图将基督历史化，所以在某种程度上，整个传统其实是一种基督教传统，因为它孕育自基督教，旨在从历史角度理解耶稣和圣经。然后人们运用这些技术，将其应用到穆斯林传统中，这就是为什么，我认为这不可避免地会在穆斯林中引起反感，因为你在运用一种外来的传统。我永远对你这种无论什么主题都能天衣无缝地得出一个非常令人信服的论点、证明这一切最终都归结为你那本关于基督教传统的优秀著作《多米尼恩》（Dominion）的能力感到叹为观止。
There you are. I've done the plug for you. Thank you. If only I could find a way to link all subjects to the second premiership of Harold Wilson in the 1970s. But of course, when and if you come to write your book on the latter years of the Thatcher premiership and into the major premiership, I hope you'll do that.
你看。我已经替你宣传过了。谢谢你。要是能找到一种方法把所有主题都跟20世纪70年代哈罗德·威尔逊的第二任首相任期联系起来就好了。当然，如果你将来要写一本关于撒切尔夫人首相任期晚期一直到梅杰首相任期的书时，我希望你也会这样做。
Then, of course, debates over the relationship of historical Mohammed to how people have interpreted and misinterpreted him absolutely becomes a part of contemporary British history because you've got the Stannic Verses and you've got everything that goes on from that. So I hope that you too will engage with this fascinating topic. The quest for the historic Margaret Thatcher.
然后，当然，关于历史上的穆罕默德与人们如何解读和误解他之间的关系的争论，绝对成了当代英国历史的一部分，因为有《撒旦诗篇》以及随之发生的一切。所以我希望你们也能参与到这个引人入胜的话题中来。寻找历史上的玛格丽特·撒切尔。
Well, that's a religious subject to turn to on another occasion. Right. I hope you enjoyed it. We'd love to hear your comments. What are we doing next time, Tom? We're doing Magna Carta, I think. So King John's partisans will have very strong views about that. And let's hope we don't get cancelled for it. All right.
好吧，那是另一个场合要探讨的宗教话题。对了。希望你们喜欢。我们很想听到你们的评论。我们下次做什么，汤姆？我想我们要做《大宪章》。所以约翰国王的支持者对此会有非常强烈的看法。但愿我们不会因此而被取消。好的。
Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。